[Musique]
je m'appelle faster moi c'est ou pas
est-ce que vous ressentez de c'est un
petit nombre a aucune c'est dommage
devenir copains
on a rendez vous mais pourquoi un rendez
vous avec lui c'est pour le tuer c'est
pourquoi il nous faut le voir mais parce
que c'est écrit dans le scénario
complètement con que cette histoire de
tuer un mec
nous venons pour vous tuez moi dans mon
scénario il a écrit sort un flingue
comment vous faites maintenant bas on
vous dit au revoir et désolé pour le
dérangement
quel est le [ __ ] t'écris toutes ces
conneries et j'en sais rien moi
présentation des scénarios séquence 17 à
5 minutes en bois une guerre qui ne sort
pas de beurre et pourquoi les deux camps
n'arrivent
le patron le redis je ne sers pas de
bière vous foutez de notre gueule je
n'ai eu aucune page vous êtes comment
alors fabrice vous pouvez contourner des
tâches pour entrer dans l'histoire ne
suis pas auteur je suis un personnage tu
me reconnais
ça fait trente ans je sais ce qu'est ce
que vous ne voulez en inventeur
d'histoire je connais un moment scénario
la même forme pour tout le monde
s'il ya une fois j'ai le sentiment de
n'avoir aimé
c'est cette musique est une femme
disparaît dans la nuit il ya toujours
une musique triste la musique
oui mais quand elle revient la musique
et joyeuse scénario de merde
c'est pas l'affirmer votre gueule je
fais comment pour les trouver ils sont
faciles à localiser ces de plus contre
la ville
[Musique]